[Music]
and welcome back everybody to a special
holiday episode of the careful boys
where today our special guest is none
other than German Chris Kringle Mr
klouse
himself hi Santa hey Santa hello you bad
boys of JK
news we got bad boys careful boys are
very
bad so today we are going to be talking
talking about a very very holiday
magical special concept what was one of
your most favorite or memorable
Christmases growing up there's so many
there's just so many sorry it's rude
they should go first let Bart go that's
probably something
sad honestly it is sad though cuz the
majority of my Christmas Christmases
growing up is um so my parents are
divorced right so I'm only with my mom
my mom would get I her friends would
give me gifts and then I would get a
gift oh this is really cool I got this
new Nerf gun my mom's oh you like it I'm
like yeah go perfect this will be great
when I give it to someone else someone
else going to like really like it so I
never had any presents I would just get
presents during Christmas yeah and my
mom would just use those presents to
give to other kids what the [__] does
she remember doing this I don't know I
don't know that's incredibly sad so I
never had I never really had presents
did you hear the
prompt the best Christmas no but she was
telling me that that's probably sad I'm
like yeah it's right cuz I have like
it's his best
Christmas 18 years I know I didn't show
up so 18 years of that and then I okay
so my best Christmas then would be the
day that me and Gio got together because
that is our anniversary oh on Christmas
how did you do it on Jesus birthday I
don't think we planned it oh that's just
like how it happened Jesus planned it
yeah just it's just how it happened and
that's when we revealed our love to each
other and that was our anniversary okay
christm is my favorite [__] time of
the year dude how do you feel about
Jesus do you not I think he's
fake you to divorc parents homes do you
still go to divorc parents home no they
take care of the that's too
confusing nobody knows what's from Santa
it's it's I waste money there it's a
loss oh what about you Nick hopefully L
less sad no I'm trying to think of like
an really ideal like Christmas that was
really tight I think it wasn't until my
older years where it's
like I don't know man Christmas day is
kind of like I don't want to say not
that tight but it's like I like the
season of it all you know what I mean
yeah and then Christmas day is
cool damn dude you're really not going
to get any presents Naughty Boy uhoh
uh-oh
get over here what the [__] are you
saying about Christmas Day you piece of
[__] what the [__] are you talking about
I swear to God on my life if I wasn't
Santa wasn't Chris [__] Creek lucky
[__] I thought you were German now you
turn
Italian turn a mobster when Sant gets
mad yeah [__] Italian comes out he
turns into a mobster what you say about
I've been all over I've been all over
for Christ sake he's Mr worldwide I've
been all Mr Mr International
he I'll say this when I started
celebrating Christmas Eve with Tiff's
family and then I do Christmas day with
my family I feel like those are cool
Christmases because you get a contrast
of of it all it just lasts longer you
know what I mean cool I don't know I
love I love the Christmas last to long
is not something Nick used
to oh my God take it easy S turn as
ready as your suit I just feel like
those are cheap shots was last May [__]
you
dude I can't what what am I supposed to
say to Santa dude yeah hey don't send
this video to kids he says [__] you
s Jesus Christ damn balls Jesus Christ I
don't even know if it's real I don't
know we'll see maybe either he's got to
come back I've been here he called you a
lucky
[__] that's so funny he's got to come
back I've been here I've been here oh
man I just got [__] I'm not jaded I'm
not jaded about it it's fine I know all
the comment is going to be oh you so
jaded about it I'm not jaded about it
I'm not Jed it's fine I've been here the
whole time [__] people say I'm jaded I'm
not [__] jaded about
it damn I remember um it was like first
grade or or maybe kind kindergart or or
something when we realized that we've
been told a lie so me and my buddy was
like we we need to
whistle oh [__]
we needed to whistle
blow so we were in class and during
Christmas everyone was like what do you
guys want to ask for Santa and then me
and my my my friend raised our hands and
we said um teacher teacher Santa's not
real he goes yes Santa's not real it's
not
real and then then they're like Joseph
and
Rayman settle down come over here right
now and we had to go talk to them in the
hallway they're like you know Santa is
real and they were just [__] [__]
and I'm like it's not real oh no you
know who's real Jesus is
real prove it [__] and I was taught not
to
lie that's that's going to be Steve show
me the proof but you know what even
after I knew that Santa wasn't real I
played to my parents as if he was real
so I could have double presence one from
Santa and one from my parents nice have
you guys ever had um a relative tell you
that Santa wasn't real yeah like an
uncle for sure just that you know that
one uncle in the family yeah yeah I
think I don't remember this but my my
family tells me my aunt told me Santa
wasn't real but I remember growing up I
always felt like I had like a
healthy s Santa's real thirsty right
now s's got to get through this hour
dude some hot
coco characterize it I just always feel
like a healthy uh skepticism about Santa
growing up but I can't I don't know if
it's because like that's what was in my
heart or because my aunt told me that
like Santa's not real [__] I feel like I
I don't even um I never even thought he
was real I just remember my parents like
I was like s is not real huh and then I
remember my mom saying something like no
but it's nice
[Laughter]
huh you know what though when when I
when I fully bought into it though I
would say that was my favorite time that
was my favorite time because like when
you you're just like anticipating it and
then I remember there was this one time
when at night I was trying to stay up
and my dad was like all right you got to
go to sleep now and I'm like all right I
got the whole milk and cookies thing um
I was like oh wait the fireplace the
fireplace is still going so I went to
the kitchen got a big old thing of water
and I [__] dumped it and then that
[__] went [__] all over the place my
dad was like what the [__] are you doing
you know and I was like but but if it's
if it's if it's hot then Santa can't
come down he's going to burn my
God so those ashes and water all over
the [__] fireplace and
[__] yeah and he was so mad I didn't get
my ass beat though cuz I think there
were just like all right something so
innocent about that Christmas I'll let
this dumb [__] slide dude he's going to
he's Saving Santa Claus sleep like oh
[__] man if I didn't take it out though
sad was going to burn his butt you know
and then the next morning um I was
[__] pissed because I left some
cookies out and I had this snowman
cookie that I wanted for myself and he
bit the Snowman he ate my cookie I gave
I left out for him I left out a pack of
cookies right and for some reason I
thought if Santa could read my mind
he'll know that this is my cookie that
I'm going to eat and this is your cookie
that you're going to eat that's true cuz
he knows know that [__] s it's not know
for telepathy you stupid [__]
you think how do you think Santa could
read your mind because they know what
you want for Christmas he knows what you
want knows if you're not you write him
letters write him a letter well that's
why I [__] up cuz then I had a snowman
cookie and I had the other cookie and I
was like what the [__] he ate the
snowman cookie what the [__] I was
saving that you thought he could read
your mind got a mind reader but that's
when it started to open up I don't like
snowman I like to bite the [__] head
off yeah the snowman cookie was [__]
eating and I was like oh is it because
of the lyrics he knows when you're
sleepy he knows when you're awake he
knows everything I think he's just
looking at you well I confuse Jesus and
Santa a lot I I don't think he just
knows with his M I think I yeah I
confused Jesus and Santa yeah Jesus has
telepathy we leave out a whole stock of
celery for the reindeer oh really so
they'll eat it yeah so like after like
ta goes to sleep we like Bunch up the
celery and then we throw it on the
ground as if like a [__] reindeer
came and bit it and then like smashed it
and we take a bite of the cookie and we
drink some of the milk did he believe it
yeah he believes it he's like oh the
reindeers came in too y got to be paying
him heavy for the Tooth Fairy then too
cuz you're [__] up his imagination
right now oh he hasn't have any lost
teeth yet too too young but we got to I
dude now y'all better pay him at least
$2 bills is a [__]
any that Sansa is not real through you
or would you prefer he just learn it
throughout the like going through the
world he's a pretty smart kid so I think
he's going to learn it pretty quickly
just on his own cuz even right now like
we do Elf on the Shelf uhhuh he's like
are you guys just staying up and then
moving it and they're like no of course
not how does Elf on the Shelf work what
do you do this corporate just
[__] up on the Shelf I think it's
supposed to it's like it's like the old
school way of like having the kids
behave so like saying like Okay the elf
is watching all day long and every day
they move like a certain place and if
they watch they really good for the
whole month then they're going to like
report to Santa and then you'll get even
more gifts you're not supposed to touch
them so every night we move elf you know
different places you know the the when I
realized how [__] broke I was is I
went to my neighbor's
house and um they did like a Christmas
like opening thing right so him and his
little brother uh the parents had some
like presents on the tree they were able
to open up and then I had my toy and
then um then they're like oh look around
the house I think Santa left you more
stuff they're like what and I I sh you
not they had like eight presents
together just all over the house and I
was like I only get one thing well two
cuz my parents and then Santa and I'm
like where the how the [__] did you get
eight from Santa and then this and I was
like they got [__] so much [__] I was
like dude that's crazy like other
families like they they give so many
things to their kids yeah that's like
taica and his cousins they Christmas day
to open it together I'm like what the
[__] there's more more toys here than I
ever had my whole life do they get more
than one present each one gets like four
five six like from aunties and uncles
you know but that's how it is though as
kids people give gifts and then as
adults you don't get [__] well it's cuz
it's so cheap all you guys want is
electronics when you're a kid you just
want some shitty [__] made out of
plastic from [__] China when you're
an adult you want a [__]
printer Santa's elves are actually
Chinese children scanner combo printer
oh there was um this is like the early
early nights think 1991 I remember there
was a Christmas coming up and uh I don't
know if you guys remember there would be
these Lego cataloges that you could get
and you could see all the Lego sets that
were like for sale yeah get it from the
toy store and then I would um like my
dad and mom would always ask me like
which ones do I like and then for
Christmas they're like oh Circle the one
that you want but then like they [__]
up my mind pretty pretty hard with how
how money worked so like my dad would
just always tell me the that all the
money he had at all times was in his
wallet so we would go to Target and I'd
be like oh I like this Lego thing he
would go oh looks like I only have $40
like and I would be like oh that's
that's the last $40 that we have so yeah
don't worry about buy you don't know
about the bank you just think yeah I
didn't know nothing about the bank so
then I would like have a realistic mind
of money so I would look at what all the
ones cost and I'd be like oh dude
there's no way they're going to be able
to buy me this one but I would Circle it
anyways just like as a wish list I would
Circle all these different sets but then
I would I remember there was one there
was a monreal set and I think it was
like almost almost 200 bucks oh it's
like one of the big ones yeah it's it
was like something like maybe like 149
or something like that but then I was
like that's the most one I ever seen 149
like that's crazy and you cired it and I
cirle it just for fun I'm like there's
no way they'll get me that but then I I
nor I circled all the normal stuff like
the little guy with the house and like
little stuff and then um like a week
before Christmas I was like messing
around under the bed of my parents room
and I found the box and they bought the
monreal
oh [__] you like oh my God I start
hyperventilating dude that's when you
got the asthma attack I was
like did you want to play with it
already no no no they gave it to Bart
and the Bart's mom gave it away no I
like I like ran to my sister and I and I
told my sister I was like I was going to
cry dude and then I IIT did you no I we
waited till Christmas and then obviously
I knew that it was in that box after
they had wrapped it and put on the tree
and then when I opened it it still felt
like I was getting for the first time
but then I think then my sister was like
he already knew oh freaking rat was
still sweet man and then for like years
that that Montreal set like my parents
had bought me so many Legos I had like
one of those almost very similar to like
what the dude had in The Lego Movie like
a city with like all the road plates you
mean what will frell had you had a whole
ass so in the living room like I had
bought so many Ro uh Road plates from KB
Toys that like there was such a complete
City and like I got the airport I had
the police station all this [__] and the
monre connected everything together and
it like ran on its own dude that's so
dope and we didn't get rid of it until I
was like maybe 11 or 12 when by the time
our dog got too big he started he
started trampling through it and we
didn't want him to trip so we took it
all apart and then I think it's still in
the garage of my parents house wow bring
it here put it on the wall that sick
actually it's worth a lot of money today
that's a that's a hardcore colle the
[__] pirate ship yes that's what I
want that's the one I wanted
the big ones we couldn't even make we
couldn't make it the elves kept on
messing up we couldn't do we couldn't
never figure it out cuz the sail part
there's no Lego part of the sale the
sale we couldn't figure it out yeah it
was just a black like stiff cloth cloth
or something how the hell does it
connect we could never get
connect no but the ship sets were really
cool I remember when um the the
Christmas [__] was like a whole thing of
like you wake up and every single day
it's December and then there's some
chist CH thing that you do like you
watch a movie or like you go to the mall
and then you see like all the Christmas
[__] and then at the D mall they had so
many like different decorations they had
a whole row of like the different Santas
of Europe and then there was like yeah
there was like the the different Santa
and one was like called black Peter and
that one was like the evil Santa and if
we wore like that is that from like
Amsterdam or like Dutch I don't know I
think I know what you're talking about
KCK my [__] ass
stole my shoes stole my wallet black
beer man right it's like and then they
would show different Santas and then my
parents would be like all right you see
that one that Santa is the kidnapper oh
my goodness making up bios for them
they're like that's the Bad Santa and
then they're like so all of these other
Santa checks out you know that's how
they get the toys everywhere because
like I mean I couldn't read back then
but later I found out it was just a
display of different Santa folklor and
cultural yeah and he goes but that one
that's black Peter and he's going to get
you and he's going to kidnap you if
you're a bad boy and I was like okay and
then they would always scare me I'm like
oh [__] black Peter something I want
to clear up right now is that Jack fros
is actually
cool he's dope dude yeah I'm like red
Santa red Santa red Sant oh black Peter
I don't know about him you know what's
the story about black Peter what's his
deal he just has a stick up his [__]
ass you know one of those guys real
entitled guy oh right yeah so it's more
black like in his attitude and and oh
yeah it's very cold it's cik okay very
cold like it's covered in Coal actually
it's not a literal thing no it was a it
was a white Santa with a black cloak and
I was sitting there with my orange
julius about to [__] piss my pants
when my parents told me the story it's
like if Gandalf had a black cat on yeah
basically yeah it's got nothing to do
with race you black race yeah got
nothing to do with race people always
think it's
race he's just a mean guy I have a
distinct memory of
my uncle he he owned toys and joys in
Hawaii when when I was a kid and uh
there was the [__] the year that the
Razor scooter was coming out oh I
remember just hellani but same thing
like I I would my dad would my parents
would never get me toys like if I got
anything I I would always get it from my
uncle or Auntie or something like that
uh and the thing was super popular but
it hadn't really come out yet but it was
just starting to like roll out and I
remember when my uncle comes to visits
um they sleep in my room him and in my
my auntie sleep in my room so I have to
sleep downstairs with like my cousins
and stuff like that even on the pull-out
couch or literally on the floor I
remember this particular Christmas cuz
all the kids came over I ended up
sleeping on the floor cuz I'm the
youngest in the family and I sleeping on
the floor and when I wake up in the
morning the [__] Razor scooter boxes
right there so I opened my eyes and I
remember as a kid just being mind blown
so heavy and I was the first kid my on
the Block that had that scooter and it
was just like the sickest feeling in the
world how did they know you wanted that
cuz I was talking about it all goddamn
day you know what I mean and like
wishing but you know you're not going to
get it like my parents would give me
jack [__] that was cool every [__]
toy I had as a kid if it wasn't like Le
more than if it was more than $12 I got
it from somewhere else you know what I'm
saying it's just like a piece of
Machinery from the
laundry bunch of hangers oh like another
hanger to my
collection this one's got foam on it so
my stuff won't S let you hang on the
thing for 5
minutes so Santa um since since you're
always the one giving and no one really
thinks about you I thought maybe uh it
would be appropriate to give Santa this
little gift right here what the [__] for
Christmas and I know how much you love
dance so what the fu Merry
Christmas what the [__] is this put on
your phone right now
Santa I'm
speechless it's so moving I'm so
emotionally touched by this thank you
thank you Joe jitsukawa thank you yeah
it's for me saying you know that Santa
is not
real you never had a gift thank you so
much Merry Christmas Bart Merry
Christmas Bart oh my
[Music]
God